hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem video ich habe den grat extra
so positioniert dass man mich hinten im
spiegel sieht
also sieht man sich jetzt quasi gerade
zwei mal hallo wobei jetzt sieht man
mich nur einmal leute ich hab neue
amazonen retouren bestellt dieses mal
einen unterschied nicht über kontakte
dann einfach auf seiner website die
quasi für jeden zugänglich ist dachte
mir bevor ihr dargestellt teste ich das
mal und schaue ob das wirklich gut ist
und ja das schauen wir uns mal an und
packen das dann gemeinsam aus ich bin
gespannt okay leute in letzter zeit
haben wir einige dieser seite geschickt
und ich fand es eigentlich ganz
interessant einfach weil es so was in
deutschland war sie zum ersten mal gibt
glaube ich also ich wusste zumindest
keine seite auf der man konkret für
einen bestimmten wert amazon retouren
kaufen kann normalerweise geht dass wir
nur so bisschen über kontakte so wir
sind hier auf ich bin billiger.de
retouren bro und hier habe ich vor
einiger zeit bestellt ochs mit warenwert
800 euro ich habe
225 euro dafür bezahlt er hatte zwischen
wieder neue sachen im angebot aber zum
retouren box im wert von 1000 euro 2.000
euro klingt ganz nett so nice so gut
gemacht genau ich hätte sogar ganze
paletten kaufen können guck mal amazon
retouren küchen kleingeräte palette von
2290 euro wichtig ist mal noch dazu zu
sagen das sind alles ungeprüfte artikel
ware ist ungeprüft das heißt er kauft es
ein von wo auch immer und verkauft es
dann weiter das ist super wichtig und
super cool dass es halt ungeprüfte ware
ist weil man sich natürlich sonst die
guten sachen raus nimmt aber wenn man
wirklich viele paletten hat dann hat man
gar nicht mehr die zeit dafür dass alles
zu kontrollieren und so deswegen glauben
war hier der seite das mal und ja ich
bin echt mal gespannt was da ankommt und
wir machen uns jetzt ran ans auspacken
so leute was geht wir sind in der
gewohnten umgebung ich weiß länger stand
nicht mehr hier gesehen außer auf einem
anderen kanal alex v und die eigentlich
heißt alexa.com jeden tag in videotheken
auf jeden fall aus hier haben wir das
paket ich muss sagen ist schon wirklich
schwer und 13 also ich liebe ja amazon
retouren irgendwie sondern meine
lieblings kartons bin mal gespannt also
ja einfach gar nicht lange drumherum
labern sondern einfach mal starten ob
sich die seite wirklich lohnt das weiß
ich nicht so ganz weil man muss ja mal
sagen die meisten leute ich vertraue ihm
da jetzt mal hat er gesagt oder das ist
ja da so hinterlegt dass die sachen
unkontrolliert weiter verschickt werden
beziehungsweise weiterverkauft werden
und sicherlich gibt es auch viele
händler die das so machen aber andere
neben sich sicherlich die guten sachen
raus deswegen bin ich einfach mal
gespannt 800 euro warenwert mindestens
und ja ihr habt ja eben alles gesehen
kommen
saugroboter hast du eigentlich standen
hier immer noch diese taschen vom
letzten video das waren ja brav ich wir
waren das 200 damen taschen und kein
schwein wollt die haben dann das war
wirklich ein größeres projekt
gleichzeitig dazu machen nochmal extra
video auf einem anderen kanal die sind
jetzt zum glück weg und ich bin froh
dass die weg sind jeremy mal rein
ok schade hier rechts mit oder was haben
wir denn hier led grau leiter super okay
also das ist auf jeden fall so ein
pflanzen licht erkennt man ja oder ich
hatte davon schon einige damit kannst du
halt deine pflanzen beleuchten natürlich
auch nicht für illegale sachen gedacht
ganz klar das ist nur für richtige
normale tulpen blumen und andere
pflanzliche boden pflanzliche pflanzen
ja genau kann man so sagen aber danke
dafür achso wo ist mein smartphone ich
wollte ja hier wenigstens einmal scannen
immer ich habe mich schon auf jeden fall
recht gute sachen gesehen gut 30 euro
kostet das trinken also ja ich mal nach
hinten als nächstes haben wir hier
tatsächlich ein saugroboter handymarke
auf den ersten blick nicht aber alter
das sieht wirklich gar entschuldigung
das sieht wirklich noch vielversprechend
aus prosenik and is love for family also
ja genau also ein saugroboter ist immer
gut schauen wir einfach mal was dafür
ging ist ist ja auch wichtig dass er
funktioniert wo ja das sieht ganz gut
aus ich würde mal sagen ist ein guck mal
hier ist nun ein roboter aber die sind
meistens gar nicht so schlecht ich habe
zum beispiel auch meiner oma ein
geschenk vor 23 jahren und die ist
absoluter fan davon wobei die sind gar
nicht so günstig wie ich gedacht hätte
kosten zwischen 160 euro vom kleinsten
modell bis hin zu tatsächlich bei über
500 euro dann hast du auch ein absaug
funktion dabei so wie ich hier bei dem
ding und die haben wir auf jeden fall
nicht den billigsten mit wisch
funktionen alles gut eingepackt ich
würde schätzen der dingen kostet 250
euro ach ja ja sogar ein code und jetzt
habe ich den code von wünschen das
dinner kann nicht sein okay leute ich
hab ihn gefunden bei kostet der 159 euro
ich dachte ein bisschen mehr aber ist ja
gar nicht so schlecht weil ich habe ja
quasi schon mit diesen beiden sachen
jetzt die 200 euro ja knapp wieder drin
wobei muss ja erstmal los werden und man
kennt das ja nur die taschen zum
beispiel habe ich auch gedacht hey da
machst du safe mindestens 1000 euro
gewinnen mit am ende waren es mit 1000
euro verlust also was lief auf jeden
fall bombay sich hierfür an einem
kräftigen applaus dankeschön weiter geht
es mit den paketen hier im moment und
wir haben hier komme ich musste jetzt
einfach mal mit weitermachen weil mich
das die ganze zeit schon so an lächelt
einfach hatte ich noch nie eine amazon-
natur schaut mal leute xbox one
controller mein lieber scholli und der
ist wirklich glaube ich komplett neues
jungs weise warte mal ab und schauen wir
mal eben schnell ein brot er schon mal
verwendet glaube nicht schaut mal ja
aber doch schon mal verwendet scheiße
aber ich würde eigentlich sagen er macht
einen guten zustand wir können ja gern
mal ich habe keine xbox mehr turtle
beach also meine erste konsole war eine
xbox aber ich kenne mich mit xbox leider
nicht mehr so wirklich aus deswegen
keine ahnung ob das original von xbox
ist auch das logo h
35 95 scheiße da habe ich mir jetzt mehr
erhofft naja gut immerhin mache weiter
batman
mascolo ich bin ja ganz gut aha ein
ganzes wir haben hier ein ganzes set
guck mal da werde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht reinpassen wir können ja mal
probieren dann mache ich das nächste
produkt einfach als batman auf ok ist es
mit hose ich probier's mal für euch da
rein zu steigen aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass es ein bisschen eng wird
und rechts rein und links das passt mir
leider nicht aber egal dafür passt mir
die maske sicherlich auch
[Musik]
weil das ist auch jetzt lediglich also
mein name ist mad men und ich scheiße
ich lebe noch das ist es sich erlaubt gw
0 2 jahre damit kann man sein handy an
irgend so ein ding kommt zum beispiel
ans auto pappen alter das ist dass
nintendos
wii-controller ja wahrscheinlich ist es
ein controller für die switche genau
keine ahnung also ich habe keine switch
aber ist richards eigentlich immer gut
ja hier haben wir irgendwelche
buntstifte weiß ich jetzt auch nicht so
ganz was ich damit machen soll mit macht
man damit juni kallas premium rush pence
die scheint aber gar nicht mal so
günstig zu sein über 30 euro okay dann
haben wir hier als nächstes alter eine
drohne das wird jetzt keine krass teure
tone sein da bin ich mir sicher aber
immerhin ohne die man auf jeden fall gut
verkaufen weil drohen gehen eigentlich
immer ganz gut weg ich bin mir jetzt mal
unsicher war eigentlich kann ich dir ja
mal kurz hier fliegen lassen oder lege
ich mal kurz die hirten und dann testen
wir die gleiche marke ja könnte zu
machen dann kann eigentlich nichts
passieren mit drohnen hab ich schon ganz
ganz schlechte erfahrungen macht vor
allem zu billig drohende mangel da ist
eine ich weiß nicht glaube es war sogar
für irgendein video also ich wusste das
nicht aber in der nähe war eine autobahn
und ich habe null die kontrolle gehabt
über die sting und dies dann so ein
bisschen vorzeitig abgestürzt zum glück
also ich so ein bisschen konnte ich noch
kontrollieren hier haben wir einen
technisat digit radio ok auch das ist
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht weil
das könnte ich auch meiner oma geben die
brauchen mich ein neues ich kann damit
auf jeden fall wenig anfangen zu hause
und radio ich nicht ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen also die 800 euro sehe ich
hier jetzt vor schwierig schwierig
schwierig aber ein bisschen was haben
wir noch sagt aha dann dual charger
system für die playstation und xbox auch
und fernbedienung hier ist natürlich
kein controller drin oder
zu früh gefreut ja warte mal sagt das
ist halt auch also ist zwar ganz nice to
have sieht erstmal cool aus aber hat
kein großen wert ist als in china
schrott dingen okay dann haben wir hier
aber noch was gutes vielleicht ein
aktien vernichter schauen wir hier leute
aktenvernichter von jenny erkenne ich
mich gar nicht aus mit aktenvernichtern
das liegt daran weil ich keine akten
vernichtet ich vernichte höchstens
andere sachen aber das sind keine akten
junge diese tracks amazon com zieht
rüber in die sind immer über dem
originalen qr code und dann kann es
natürlich nicht kennen ich kann das
jetzt abziehen und dann bleibt ja die
hälfte kleben meinen das hat natürlich
einen sinn dass das so ist aber es regt
mich auf schwierig also irgendwas
zwischen 15 und 50 euro wobei ich würde
meiner tippen so auf 20 euro vielleicht
jetzt auch nicht so besonders macht da
fällt mir auf ich habe ja immer noch
dieses batman ding hier an was haben wir
denn noch hier habe ich noch irgendwie
landen wir bei kissen für brüste ach nee
das ist ja ganz komische schrieben für
gehörs trost bürostuhl aha alles klar
also ich habe hier hinten sondern dingen
das ist eigentlich so was ähnliches
glaube ich das ist ein ergonomisches
kissen da wird man immer gesund sitzt
aber viel oder auch benutzen tue ich das
nicht weil irgendwie komme ich mir dabei
immer ungesünder vor wenn ich dann auf
dem ding drauf sitze ja und dann geht es
weiter wenn so eine nintendo 64 ist das
glaube ich genau 25 classic games
included okay es ist ein joystick den
man am pc wahrscheinlich anschließen
kann und dann kannst du darüber zocken
bin ich gar nicht so schlecht von
speedlink ist das denn und kostet 29
euro also wirklich jetzt dass mörder
teil okay der saugroboter ist absolut in
ordnung und es ist definitiv keine
moment kurz schaut mal hier haben wir
noch sony kopfhörer sony wh wh 510 hier
kann man denke ich mal noch ein bisschen
mehr rausholen die werden sicherlich 80
euro kosten
30 euro kommen also hier hatte ich
wirklich gedacht dass die teurer sind
hier haben wir noch so ein bisschen wie
ein kopfhörer kosten zehner die hier
vielleicht auch nochmals ein zehner jvc
zumindest christi die nicht viel mehr
los und das hier ist noch dass
vielleicht ist hier auch noch was
sonntag beleuchtungssystem also es ist
ein lüfter den ich im internet für 29
euro finde auch wieder oder knapp 29
euro also auch jetzt nix sonderbares und
hier haben wir noch einen projektor das
kann man zum beispiel hier hinten
hinstellen dann leuchtet das ich weiß
nicht sehen können so leicht ping ich
habe davon auch ein paar hier weit ist
dass hier noch tripod safestick und nun
microsoft surface pen tritt sogar ein
preis auf 20 euro also ich will nicht
sagen dass ich enttäuscht bin weil ab
auf jeden fall mit den produkten
sicherlich wenn man alle verkaufen würde
die 200 euro wieder drin man muss
allerdings sagen dass die produkte zum
großen teil nicht wirklich leicht
verkaufbar sind bis auf zwei drei
ausnahmen vielleicht und ich denke mal
es wird nicht so einfach die 200 euro
wieder reinzuholen aber gut ich würde
trotzdem gehe alles zusammenrechnet
kleines fazit ziehen und wir sehen uns
dann gleich noch machen also bevor ich
es vergesse wir müssen einmal hier die
drohne test h drohen pflicht nämlich
sehr gern sagt ach ja das also man sieht
schon das ist leider eine absolute bülow
drohne die wahrscheinlich nach zwei
meiner luft liegen kaputt ist die erst
laden bekommt man geht sogar an auch und
hier war dann direkt den nächsten xbox
controller dabei da müssen
wahrscheinlich batterien rheine habe ich
mir schon gedacht okay das können der
witzig werden ja hier tut sich was
bleibt mal an wichtig ist auch mit
solchen drohen wirklich in deutschland
deshalb oder wenn ihr eine große
landwirtschaft fliegt meinetwegen aber
das ist wirklich meiner meinung nach
viel zu gefährlich weil die einfach voll
unkontrollierbar sind deswegen fliege
ich dir jetzt nochmal hier drin weil
hier kann eigentlich nicht so viel
kaputt gehen nur ein bisschen ja kommen
leute schaut mal hier ist sogar eine
kamera daran gehabt bestimmte kranke
auflösungen ja was ist jetzt hier klipp
speed und sogar ein speed modus muss ich
jetzt tatsächlich die beschreibung lesen
alter ich hasse beschreibung
[Musik]
landon landen
ich muss sagen die weißt doch sehr
kontrolliert am anfang das hätte ich
nicht gedacht aber das war es ein
bisschen dumm aber jetzt haben wir hier
irgendwelche kratzer irgendwelche
verletzte entschuldigung hallo alles
noch heile hier ist eine fliege
vielleicht kann ich die marken hallo
was ist das dauert halt irgendwie bis
die sich verbinden da kommen jetzt los
abfahrt verbindung
meine lieben ich habe mir noch mal alles
genau anguckt und muss sagen ja die box
war in ordnung natürlich sind wir ganz
ganz weit weg von 800 euro warenwert
beziehungsweise 800 euro sap keine
ahnung finde ich schwierig ich kann euch
jetzt nur sagen wenn ich das theoretisch
alles verkaufen würde oder die top
produkte verkaufen würde was ich damit
dann circa verdienen könnte bei einigen
sachen habe ich schon im preis gesagt
dass radio was wir hatten ist gar nicht
mal so günstig also das konzert im
internet auch immer 1 70 euro ich denke
für jahr 50 55 sollte das weggehen dann
hatten wir ein saugroboter die gehen
eigentlich immer ganz gut würde ich mal
so mit 135 ansätzen die sony kopfhörer
dann hatten wir noch den mini controller
für die nintendos switch wo und dann
auch noch die drohne ich hatte gedacht
das ist nur 35 euro drohne die kostet
auf amazon aber tatsächlich 80 euro aber
weise nicht werde ich natürlich niemals
bekommen aber wenn die 440 weggehen
sollte theoretisch ist es okay und mit
allen produkten weiß ich nicht würde ich
mal schätzen dass man so 300 bis 340
euro verdienen kann das heißt ich hab
mir grad noch mal die rechnung
angeschaut 220 euro habe ich bezahlt
also dann hätte ich wenn es gut läuft
über 100 euro daran verdient naja war
trotz mal ganz interessant die seite für
euch aus zu checken und leute ich
bedanke mich fürs zuschauen wir sehen
uns hier die nächsten tage wieder es
komme auf jeden fall jetzt wieder einige
coole videos haut rein heute abonniert
sagen den kanal wir sehen uns ja